[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité du
département voici les titres de ce
vendredi 19 mai et une nouvelle étape de
franchie pour l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et les élus ont voté
hier la définition des intérêts
communautaires après dix-huit mois de
tractations et de tension ces intérêts
prendront effet le 1er janvier 2018
jean-marc mon billet est l'invité de
cette émission le président de
l'association autisme en yvelines nous
évoquerons avec lui les missions de la
structure et la situation des personnes
autistes en france souvent oubliés des
politiques publiques et enfin dans le
reste de l'actualité et retour sur le
déplacement mercredi à trappes du
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur gérard
colomb encore le lancement officiel du
premier vignoble franciliens dans les
yvelines
je vous le disais en titre c'est
probablement le véritable point de
départ de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines élargi à 12 communes
les élus de l'agglomération ont approuvé
jeudi soir la définition des intérêts
communautaires l'enjeu était capital
puisqu'il pose clairement la frontière
entre les compétences des villes et
celle de l'agglomération les précisions
et les détails avec ce reportage
les discussions auront duré un an et
demi les intérêts communautaires sont
désormais votée à la quasi-unanimité un
soulagement pour l'ensemble des élus est
le fruit de longues négociations entre
majorité et opposition
il ya des moments où on va certains vont
plus loin que ce qui pouvait espérer en
prêtant mais d'autres heureusement il
faut savoir frais d donc c'est toujours
un compromis qu'il faut savoir retrouver
lorsque l'on doit arrêter sur des
intérêts quant à terre
concrètement les 74 élus de saint
quentin en yvelines ont arrêté neuf
compétences dont 6 dites obligatoires
parmi celles ci la création et la
réalisation de zack ou encore l'ensemble
de la politique liée au logement plus
débattue elle les compétences
optionnelles comporte la gestion des
voiries et celle des équipements
culturels et sportifs le ciné 7 et le
prisme d'elancourt sortent des
compétences de l'agglomération la
piscine intercommunale de maurepas elle
n'y entre pas je fais donc la
proposition avec mes collègues
d'elancourt et de coignières voilà de ne
plus transférer la piscine de maurepas à
50 en 10 10 mais de négocier un fonds de
concours pour le sport et la culture
donc il y aura bien une piscine qui sera
intercommunale non pas communautaire
intercommunale construite par les trois
villes sur les territoires de maurepas
mais l'effet de financière de 50 ans qui
viennent au travers d'un fonds de
concours
ce nouvel outil financier pour la
construction de la nouvelle piscine sera
soumis au vote des élus à la fin du mois
de juin les intérêts communautaires
prendront eux effet à partir du 1er
janvier 2018
on poursuit cette émission avec notre
avis d notre invité de ce vendredi
jean-marc mon billet bonsoir pour soi
vous êtes le président d'autisme en
yvelines
une association spécialisée dans
l'accompagnement des personnes autistes
de tout âge dans le département je cite
là dans le texte ce qui est écrit sur
votre site internet ça c'est pour la
présentation du côté concret que faites
vous qu'est ce que vous proposez
justement quand vous parlez
d'accompagnement des personnes autistes
alors effectivement le sommes depuis 26
ans spécialisée dans l'accompagnement de
patriotisme dans les yvelines
nous accompagnons 145 jeunes de trois
ans à 56 ans parce que pour nous c'est
toujours des jeunes et il ya 140
professionnels à leur côté qu'ils
accompagnent tous les jours alors votre
principale mission c'est de gérer des
établissements qui sont au nombre de 2
400 à 3 établissements et un service
mais notre mission c'est d'être
développeur de services
et quand on a quand on réussit à mettre
en place un service et de le gérer avec
des professionnels et c'est aussi d'être
militant avec les familles et pour faire
avancer les droits
alors vous le disiez trois
établissements et services qui sont pour
des personnes de tout âge donc il ya des
établissements pour des personnes pour
des jeunes enfants d'autres peaux nous
on parle de parcours de l'autisme
à partir du moment où au moins je des
diagnostics et sévère de 3 ans un long
parcours se dessine devant lui et il
faut l'accompagner à chaque période et
j'ai mieux géré chaque âge charnière
donc au début ça commence à l'école donc
le bon service qui accompagne le jeune
en inclusion scolaire s'appelle un
sessad ça peu technique mais c'est comme
ça il faut un sessad de 75 places ici
après deux prêts d'ici à
montigny-le-bretonneux il ya une
première u10 qui a été créé il ya 15 ans
et puis plus récemment dans la craie une
à une en cours mais on y reviendra je
crois on a un ime institut
médico-éducatif carrières sous poissy de
30 places si on a un foyer de vie pour
adultes autistes et vieillissant aux
années le roi donc ça ça fait 145
personnes absolument en tout alors ma
question va peut-être vous paraître un
peu un peu un peu bête un peu naïve mais
est-ce que ça ça répond aux besoins du
département sur les personnes autistes
ça répond vous vous doutez la réponse à
rien absolument pas au besoin les
besoins sont immenses
là quatre cent mille personnes autistes
en france le taux de prévalence est le
nombre de personnes autistes qui
naissent tous les ans c'est 1% voire un
port 80 et les besoins sont largement
supérieures par rapport aux moyens mis
en place
on a progressé année après année mais
c'est loin d'être suffisant
par exemple sur le département des
yvelines vous vous seriez un nombre qui
serait satisfaisant de places
disponibles sans avoir un chiffre précis
évidemment mais vous avez dix et
quelques centaines qu'on ne dit pas
disponible c'est soit places disponibles
dans des structures fermées foyer
foyer d'aidé médicalisée où il me oudin
des structures plus ouverte que jean
scolaire mais en gros ces quelques
centaines et les besoins ces quelques
milliers donc il ya un facteur 10
entrées de vous diriez qu'on est sur un
département même si l'offre est
insuffisante plutôt bien fournie sur la
question ou au contraire en dessous de
la moyenne nationale est ce que vous
avez un regard là-dessus sur le rhône a
même dû regard nous on pense qu'on est
absolument pas bien fourni mais mais
tout est relatif il vu de la région ile
de france
les evil ces départements le mieux
fournis alors vous le disiez il ya
quelques secondes une nouvelle structure
qui a ouvert ses portes récemment à
elancourt pour accueillir des enfants
autistes dès la maternelle
est ce que d'autres projets qui sont
j'imagine bon puisque la prise en charge
plus elle arrive tôt mieux c'est pour
les enfants est ce qu il yad autres
prise en charge de ce genre qui vont se
faire dans l'avenir d'autres centres qui
va ouvrir tous les cinq ans il ya un
plan autisme qui est décidée par le
gouvernement le plan autisme 3 qui vient
c'est de se terminer là maintenant a
décidé de créer une nouvelle unité
d'enseignement maternel par département
alors évidemment les yvelines c'est pas
la même chose qu'un département plus
rurales les besoins sont supérieurs mais
la première le m a été ouverte à
elancourt à la rentrée scolaire dernière
hainard une deuxième aux mureaux 1 c'est
effectivement la meilleure solution
parce qu on accueille les enfants très
jeunes à trois ans c'est entre 3 et 7
ans il ya sept enfants et c'est la
meilleure structure parce que c'est
adapté parce qu'elle est professionnel
spécialisé et parce que c'est un dans un
établissement ordinaire donc c'est
excellent pour ça combien d'enfants sont
scolarisés à elancourt 7,7 donc
j'imagine que la liste d'attentes là
aussi doit être est énorme et même des
familles qui ont désiré pour aller à
elancourt parce que c'est la meilleure
solution
alors vous le disiez tout à l'heure on
estime aujourd'hui que les chiffres vous
disiez 400000 personnes aujourd'hui sont
atteints de troubles d'autisme moi
j'avais 650 milles ça prouve que les
chiffres sont difficiles à établir tout
à fait bref du coup c est sujet à
beaucoup de clichés ça a beaucoup
d'idées reçues et puis finalement on se
pose pas la question la plus simple mais
qu'est ce que c'est l'autisme est ce que
vous pourriez définir ça en quelques
mots vont très rapidement même si un
jour pour lui la solution impossible de
définir en quelques mots l'autisme n'est
pas une maladie infantile c'est un
handicap on ne guérit pas de l'autisme
on peut progresser on peut gagner en
autonomie mais l'autisme c'est un
handicap
voilà et donc effectivement plus
on détecte plus tôt en diagnostic mieux
on est armé pour aider le jeune à gagner
en autonomie et à gagner en inclusion
dans la société
que ce soit à l'école que ce soit au
travail alors justement là aussi comme
on peut détecter peut-être un début
d'une forme d'autisme chez un enfant est
ce qu'il ya des signes qui permet de
voir ça un peu à l'avant ce l'absence de
paroles gestes serreau typique absence
de regards absence de communication
tous ces signaux là le pédiatre devrait
être capable de le faire mais le médecin
pédiatre il faut savoir que la formation
sur le trouble autistique
pendant ces dix ans de médecine c'était
quelques heures donc on a un vrai
déficit de diagnostic précoce et c'est
parce qu'on n'arrive pas au niveau
national a détecté suffisamment précoce
que derrière c'est plus compliqué il y à
aussi il faut le faut le rappeler
peut-être le souligner c'est important
mais différentes formes d'autisme tous à
différents degrés il ne se valent pas
tous certains sont quasiment peu
perceptible et les gens ne le voient pas
forcément on n'avait pas le déceler oui
c'est vrai on ne prend pas de titre on
parle de troubles du spectre autistique
donc ça va évidemment deux premiers
autiste qui a démocratisé la cause qui
est leur henman le film mais ça c'est
autistes 10 au niveau asperger 1 mais il
ya tous les spectres autistique il ya
des autistes qui gronde autre handicap
et là c'est beaucoup plus beau but
sérieux globalement les autorités
publiques les associations essaient de
faire beaucoup de choses pour changer le
regard de la société sur sur l'autisme
est ce que vous diriez qu'aujourd'hui il
ya du progrès que le regard change sur
dans notre société ou au contraire
qu'ils n'évoluent que très peu ou pas du
tout on est encore très loin de la
tolérance dans certains pays comme la
belgique comme les états unis 1 mais ça
mais quand on regarde ce qui s'y passait
depuis quelques années on a fait de gros
progrès mon fils était en inclusion
scolaire
là où là où j'habite un petit village
rural un 1/4 d'heure toutes les semaines
le vendredi après midi en passant par la
porte de derrière
quelques années après l'école
massivement a demandé qu'on installe
chez elle une classe pour les autistes
donc n'en a pas profité mais c'est bien
exemple que la société a évolué et que
et contrebasse
alors la société volume et vous disiez
des pays en avance sur tous les états
unis la belgique à quoi est ce dû c'est
une culture différente c'est une des
campagnes de communication dans les
médias différentes c'est une culture 10
et des moyens c'est une cause nationale
avec des moyens associés donc l'autisme
est une cause nationale c'est vrai qu'on
a des plans autisme tous les cinq ans je
disais à la fin du plan autisme 3 mai
les moyens sont pas encore à l échelle
votre association vous lui disiez aussi
propose d'accompagner les personnes
autistes
tout au long de leur vie et pour ça vous
placez là aussi un j'ai lu votre site
internet vous placer au coeur de votre
action le projet de vie de la personne
dans le respect de la charte des droits
de la personne autiste est ce que vous
pouvez m'expliquer ça concrètement la
personne autiste et les autistes
c'est une personne à la droite pour
retrouver sur tous les sites
d'associations qui oeuvrent dans le
secteur de l'autisme
le projet de vie personnalisé c'est le
projet de vie qu'on construit avec le
jeune sa famille et tous les
professionnels qui qui l'accompagnent 1
est ce un projet de vie qui détecte les
acquis et les émergences et qui définit
les priorités dans l'année qui vient
voilà et ça c'est un projet de vie il
doit être construit avec la famille il
est construit avec des professionnels et
qui peut former à au travail aussi plus
tard sinon temps assez long confisage
est vite dans tout le parcours de
l'autisme il est différent à trois ans
qu'à 50 à 10 ans et à chaque fois ce qui
est avec l'état qui doit être consolidé
1 ce qui émerge comme compétences et une
expertise doit être progresser je
voudrais aborder à un autre thème de
votre association c'est l'accompagnement
des familles des aidants vous organiser
des rencontres pour eux des ateliers d
accueil conseil
c'est la troisième mission de
l'association on est l'association de
parents donc on doit aider les parents
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de parents il ya
beaucoup d'aidants qui n'ont pas la
chance d'avoir jeunes en établissement
ou ou pris en pris en charge par des
dans les services donc il faut les aider
et bien souvent la première chose qu'on
fait vis-à-vis de ces familles puiser
dans ces de leur passé le témoignage de
ce qu'on a vécu avant l insu de
communication sur les démarches
administratives et sur ce qu'on appelle
les troubles sensoriels
c'est la priorité il faut expliquer aux
familles ce qui se passe et comment
décoder portant leurs enfants parce que
bien souvent ils sont démunis quand ils
vous sollicite i quels sont les aussi
les autres besoins qui peuvent exprimer
sa besoin d'écouté d'orientation ça peut
être parfois de compliqué de s'y
retrouver avec tous les établissements
qui peuvent exister les sigles on en
parlait tout à l'heure quand on découvre
que son jeune est autiste
c'est le choc 1 et on sait pas quoi
faire on est totalement démunis et donc
faut qu'on les aide
notre famille a comprendre a décollé à
savoir ou faire un diagnostic à savoir
où se renseigner pour inclure l'enfant à
l'école et ça c'est un c'est beaucoup de
travail
on a à peu près 100 familles et tous les
ans qui ne contacte au travers des sites
internet et on est prêt nous sommes
passés par là à les aider on parle et on
disait que les personnes autistes était
parfois oubliés des politiques publiques
il manquait des places est-ce que leurs
familles lésées dont on peut les mettre
dans ces catégories là aussi enfin cette
catégorie là d oublier n'en ont pas dire
ça parce que il ya dans les plan autisme
nationaux il y a eu des actions pour les
aidants la région ile de france a mis en
place des aides d'ailleurs elle nous a
subventionné pour les campagnes d'aidé
aux aidants non en les aidant ils sont
accompagnés le kreis le sens de retour
sottise l'île de france fait des choses
pour les aidants il ya beaucoup de
choses
il suffit juste d'aller sur google et
entre tout ça sur google ou sur votre
site international bien sûr à ew points
au tice m'tir et en tirer yvelines point
fr un jour pointe et excusez moi juste
un petit coup d'oeil maintenant sur
votre sur votre calendrier à venir
puisque vous organiser des conférences
des rencontres la prochaine c'est mardi
23 mai donc la semaine prochaine à noisy
le roi avec une conférence sur les
troubles sensoriels en autisme est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire quelques
mots sans forcément tout dévoiler tout
de suite mais nous parler de ce rendez
vous alors nous
une tâche qui est là c'est un peu voilà
c'est là si on organise une série de
conférences sur des thèmes outils de
communication démarche ministre hâtives
et troubles sensoriels et là c'est un
oasis le 23 mars est à 20 heures
inscription libre vous allez sur le site
de l'association vous inscrire c'est
totalement gratuit et vous allez
apprendre beaucoup de choses sur les
trous sensorielle qui souvent sur la
cause de comportements à problèmes chez
les autistes et puis il y a plein
d'autres rendez vous que l'on peut
retrouver sur le site internet
www.iobis.org tirer yvelines point org
merci jean marc mon billet d'être venu
en plateau merci à vous c'est poursuit
tout de suite cette émission avec le
reste de l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
et cette semaine a été marquée pas
forcément par par la politique le
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur gérard
collomb a effectué son premier
déplacement mercredi dans les yvelines
il s'est notamment rendu au commissariat
de trappes où il est revenu sur
plusieurs affaires de délinquance qui
touchent la ville miquel et demi d'euros
étaient sur place
gérard collomb n'a pas perdu tant quatre
heures après avoir été nommé ministre de
l'intérieur l'homme politique est venu
au commissariat de trappes pour son tout
premier déplacement officiel
objectif rencontrer les forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain
il a également évoqué avec eux la ferme
à licques du nom de cet homme soupçonné
d'assassinât et de tentatives
d'assassinats à plaisir et attrapes
je pense que c'est quelque chose
évidemment de dramatique qui est
extrêmement grave et plutôt que d'aller
visiter des lieux vous effectivement il
n'y a pas de difficultés j'ai souhaité
venir ici pour me faire expliquer la
problématique ce que font les enquêteurs
et comment on va arrêter le plus vite
possible
ce criminel gérard collomb a été
accueillie par le maire socialiste de la
commune guy malandain deux hommes qui se
sont côtoyés sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale
un plaisir humains dans la rencontre
après que je ne tirais choisi de venir
ici je le prends comme une préoccupation
par rapport à un évènement familial qui
s'est passé mais qui ne l'est pas
nom de la ville pour l'accueillir
également une dizaine de militants de la
république en marche pour eux cette
visite de 20 minutes est un signe fort
envoyé par le nouveau gouvernement
tout ce qu'on travaille comme disait le
président dès sa nomination il est venu
à trappes pour nous soutenir
c'est très bien au moins on va là tu n'y
as pas parole on va la direccte là ça
c'est très bien moi je trouve gérard
collomb ensuite poursuivi sa visite dans
les îles par une rencontre avec les
gendarmes de saint germain en laye et
des pompiers à chanteloup-les-vignes
attrape toujours les représentants
locaux du ps du front national et des
républicains étaient appelés à débattre
mercredi soir avec l a fédération du
bâtiment yvelines la soirée était
articulée autour de 112 propositions
établies par la fédération dans le cadre
des élections législatives un reportage
de stéphane servant après la
présentation des 112 proposition du btp
les candidats présents avaient à chaque
fois un temps pour répondre et faire
leurs propositions aux professionnels du
bâtiment devant un public attentif
ils ont les uns après les autres exposer
leurs idées et fait part de leur soutien
un secteur important de l'économie
locale le bâtiment représente en effet
cinquante mille entreprises mais aussi
15 mille pme et 35 mille artisans dans
leur quotidien les artisans et chefs
d'entreprises du bâtiment souhaitent
avant tout qu'on leur simplifie la vie
il semble avoir été entendu par les
candidats principale demande le besoin
de simplification administrative
réponses des candidats
aujourd'hui pour réaliser un chantier
toutes les autorisations en amont et
toutes les contraintes pour réaliser
sont telles que
on démobilise je dirais les entreprises
la concertation et la simplification
pour les entreprises du bâtiment me
paraît être un point très important déjà
alors c'est pas les seuls parce qu'il ya
en même temps tout ce qui concerne la
formation est aussi l'apprentissage
s'est créé un guichet unique pour les
formalités administratives pour toutes
les tpe pme qui sont très nombreuses
dans le secteur du bâtiment de la
crainte aussi exprimé à l'heure du débat
sur les travailleurs détachés par le
développement d'une économie à deux
vitesses
fondée sur le dumping social et la
précarisation de l'emploi
un débat de très belle tenue où l'on a
regretté l'absence du candidat de la
république en marche
ils étaient une quarantaine jeudi midi
réunis devant les locaux aux yvelinois
de la direction régionale du travail à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats ces
agents dépendant du ministère du travail
et manifesté pour s'opposer à la
suppression prévue de plusieurs postes
sur l'ensemble de la région francilienne
reportage tracts à la main autocollant
sur la veste ses membres de la cgt
essaie tant bien que mal d'interpeller
les passants près de la gare de montigny
le bretonneux
le service public c'est le bien de ceux
qui n'ont pas de bien rassembler devant
l'union départementale de la direction
du travail
il dénonce l'austérité qui touche leur
ministère presque 2000 postes supprimés
en france depuis 2009 285 en ile de
france et bientôt quatre supplémentaires
sur le département des yvelines
les agents troupes qui contrôlent un
secteur géographique donné le secteur où
automatique - s'agrandir du coup les
agents nous ne plus pouvoir rendre
service public de qualité aux usagers
puisque on aura de plus en plus de
travail on nous demande de faire quand
même le travail qu'on faisait avant avec
20% des effectifs en dix ans et à un
moment donné on ne peut plus fonctionner
décidé avant la présidentielle ce
mouvement était prévue aujourd'hui sur
l'ensemble des régions la récente
victoire d' emmanuel macron ne semble
pas les rassurer le nouveau président
prévoit de réformer rapidement le code
du travail qui dit réforme est d'initier
n'est pas du travail dit forcément pour
nous agents chargés du contrôle de ces
codes plus de difficultés
plus de problèmes à venir contacté par
nos soins la direction régionale du
travail n'a pas donné pour l'instant de
réponse à nos sollicitations
en 2020 il sera possible de déguster du
chardonnay du merlot ou encore du pinot
noir 100% franciliens c'est une première
à dravemont dans les yvelines
mardi plus de 16 mille pieds de vignes
ont été plantées sur 3 ha reportage de
wilfrid richy sur des images d'une
première les terrains acquis un sous-sol
calcaire et au vent léger à quelque 100
mètres d'altitude sur ce plateau à
d'avron les conditions semblent est
idéal à la maturation des raisins et
donc à l'obtention d'un vin de grande
qualité
on plante du chardonnay du chemin en
blanc et en plantes du merlot et du
pinot noir en rouge
donc c'est des choix de ces pages qu'on
a fait en fonction des potentiels de
maturité qui a ici en fonction du climat
fonction des sols aussi on a fait des
choix de cépage pour certains qui sont
habituellement cultiver un peu plus au
sud
et on souhaite faire un pari d'avenir en
les amenant un peu plus au nord pour les
amener en limite de maturité âgés de 27
à 31 ans julien bru style c'est julien
bengué et adrien pélissier sont les
trois fondateurs de la winery parisienne
ce sont eux qui ont eu l'idée
d'installer dans les yvelines le premier
vignoble professionnels d'ile-de-france
un vignoble de 16 les pieds l'objectif
commercial ces deux c'est de pouvoir
faire découvrir localement ces vins là
les rendre abordable au plus grand
nombre
que distribuons filières courtes et en
circuit court pour que les yvelinois
puissent profiter du fruit de leur
terroir le département soutient
l'initiative
pour son président l'objectif est aussi
de renforcer le caractère rural des
yvelines je ne pensais pas qu'on pouvait
très honnêtement faire du vin à des fins
commerciales dans le département des
yvelines et le réchauffement climatique
l'imagination de ces jeunes gens
maintenant convaincus et donc oui on
fait le pari avec eux et je suis
convaincu que ce serait un pari gagnant
les premières vendanges sont attendus
pour 2020 si l'essai est concluant dont
l'exploitation pourrait atteindre les 26
hectares a rendez vous à noter
maintenant dans vos agendas le centre
horticole d'enseignement et de promotion
assez aussi appelé le chai participent
samedi à la 11e édition de la fête de la
nature de nombreuses animations autour
des animaux sont prévues et notamment
sur les pouvoirs magiques des animaux
mercredi nous recevions à ce sujet
laurent carle directeur de
l'établissement regarder le faucon
pèlerin par exemple et ben 390 km heure
380 dollars et ben si si ça c'est pas un
super pouvoir
voilà également un autre petit indice on
connaît
pour les initiés au moins la barben et
bien les fruits de la bardane c'est ce
qui a inspiré l'inventeur du velcro un
accord et c'est également un super
pouvoir
voilà et puis je vais pas forcément tout
dévoiler aujourd'hui mais quand on parle
également de l'orage des éclairs cette
énergie monumentale qui est en quelques
secondes se déchaînent c'est également
assez fabuleux quand même un autre
rendez vous à noter dans vos agendas
musicale est cette fois ci avec la
nouvelle création de la compagnie pavé
volubile c rise up qui est à découvrir à
la ferme de bel ébat ce samedi 20 mai 55
minutes précisément pour voyager à
travers des contes et récits
afro-américain à une réflexion aussi sur
le racisme et les esclavages un
reportage réalisé par patrick jacques de
dixmude et mélinda correia
[Musique]
chocolat
un ton joyeux des visages souriants une
contrebasse entraînante avec rise up
praliné gay-para hélène labarrière parle
de manière facétieuse du racisme et de
l' esclavage raise up si on voulait
traduire
souvenez vous et c'est aussi
avec les deux plein de mouvements de
protestation aux états unis sur plein de
pages qui sont de la classe naturelle
le fed de st
le théâtre comme tout un spectacle
vivant comme toute création comme but
ultime que les gens se posent des
questions c'est pas même donné des
réponses et des récits de tradition
orale des comptes afro américains et
caribéens rise up est un aboutissement
de 30 ans de travail
le jazz musiques emblématiques de la
traite négrière a aussi toute sa place
de nous entendre les mots qui ne sont
pas 10 puis
de donner aussi une dimension poétique
qui ailleurs être que la musique raconte
aussi l'histoire qui est peut-être pas
la même lui a fait rater l'histoire ce
principal déjà ses proches m le cri
puisque cette même salle des parts et
d'autres produits pour la joute dessus
des mentions théâtrale
c'est là contre l'arrestation de taxes
elles m'ont c't'histoire adultes où
l'enfant les lectures sont multiples
rise up ou la démonstration que l'
esclavage appartient à notre histoire
commune enfin on referme cette émission
sur la troisième édition de la nuit
européenne des musées
tous les ans c'est une occasion de
visiter vos musiques préférées sous un
angle original ce samedi soit le musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
vous propose une programmation autour du
rétro gaming entre 19h et 22h30
le musée national de port royal des
champs à magny-les-hameaux participe
également à l'événement avec un concert
promenade pour fêter la musique du xviie
et xviiie siècles toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
site
qu'est-ce que point est-ce qu y point fr
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivis retrouver tous nos
reportages on replay sur tv fil 78
points comme bon week-end à tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]